ever gonna catch him that's not gonna
happen who is just a total different
world and a lot of that is his deep
knowledge and understanding something
and you being a smart guy
I think you'd get into it especially
because you love pro wrestling so
there's like there's like you have them
at least you have a mindset for watching
guys do things to each other and
manipulate each other which is half of
what's exciting about pro wrestling
right some guy pulling off some crazy
move even if it's orchestrated it's
still a crazy thing that these guys are
pulling off on each other yeah I mean I
I like that more because then I'm like
oh they're friends and they work this
out together my problem is I know
they're getting hurt and then not even
really fighting mm-hmm right I mean
they're it's they're hitting each other
for sure they're doing things to each
other and slamming each other it's all
real those guys get banged up and they
do it way more so if you're watching a
guy who's fighting in the UFC
they have practices that they can
control so if they know that they have a
hurt you know back or a hurt foot you
know they'll put shit and instead pass
on they won't they won't kick they'll do
things will they work around whatever
injury they have whether when they're in
the camp you can't do that when dudes
are throwing you something you got a bad
back and some guys fucking picking you
up bang well they will you know they'll
adjust what moves they will do but I do
really like your point about these they
can take some time off yeah definitely
just I'm sure yeah they can definitely
make an agreement with each other hey
don't slamming my back is fucked but
those guys get beat the fuck up talking
to dowse Paige and jake the snake' two
guys that have had on the podcast which
were they were amazing and especially
Jake stories fucking crazy man yeah when
he tells you his story and what a nice
guy big giant nice man like just
genuinely friendly and and happy that
everything's going well for him now
crazy but that's how rough business is
my point
like I'm Way rather like real grappling
I feel like real grappling for like if
Ella's gonna tell a person like what
would be safer for your body
I think pro wrestling's harder I think
it's harder on you
I can see that don't think it's Who I am
you watch some of that stuff but knowing
what you know now about brain damage and
knowing what you know now about that
it's not even concussions necessarily as
much as its sub concussive trauma it
doesn't knock you unconscious but just
rattles your fucking head and the
repeated impacts of those yeah those
guys are getting that all the time
yeah all the time yeah no I go back and
sometimes I watch some older wrestling
and it really makes me cringe is you got
a lot of guys taking all these chair
shots straight to the face straight to
the face yeah so can't ken Shamrock take
this one to the head that sounded like a
gunshot it was crazy
yeah dude what is it about people
getting smacked in the head um Tom Segar
has been sending me these Russian
slapped Championships his video have you
seen this shit oh my god these guys
stand in front of each other and smack
each other in the face full clip but
some of them are doing a terrible job
they're hitting with their finger at
occasion my finger they're getting
fingers and then there's other guys that
are basically doing like a ridge hand
strike to your neck they're clipping
guys on the chin like this and they
follow through that looks like a slap
but this is not a slap this this is like
a karate chop they're like going like
that to the head and then it turned mean
it's way harder and then some guys are
doing like a boss fruit and palm strike
they're hitting like this they're doing
like a right hook to the head like that
it's brutal
guys are get knocked unconscious I like
to see it but just with like older black
moms there used to be the dumbest thing
ever it was called like X arm and they
would tape these guys arms together and
let them have an MMA fight
what it was an MMA fight slash arm
wrestling competition and they were
taped together it sounds so stupid you
can't imagine that not only was it real
but that the guy who created it was one
of the original creators of the UFC like
it's such a great idea they just went
for it man look they taped these people
together their arms are taped together
they can't
move away and then when they say go they
start fighting come on they get an arm
bars this guy folks this guy's arm up
dude he broke his arm on the table a
hundred percent if that guy keeps
pulling on that thing he gets his arm
snapped ya know I don't know if he
actually broke her right there but if
the way the leverage of that table get
that guys can't kicked in the fucking
head while he's tied to that guy's arm
it's crazy
pin his arm that pin his arm or kale him
to win what what what didn't work I mean
it didn't lie just how crazy people can
get I love it
dude but that's real and now this is the
other one chessboxing this is a legit
one too I think they box first and then
they play chess right I think it goes
back and forth
oh they keep going back and forth that's
a good move but seriously if you take a
oh dang what if you get ko
do you win yeah if you win addition zero
one yeah like if you win it trust me you
get flatlined in 30 seconds
whoo that's also be really fun if
there's people who are horrible at
fighting but really good it yes yeah and
they would just lay down yeah you win
you win this part I'm just here for the
chest
I suck at chess why do they have
headphones on focus do you think so yeah
really while you're playing chess I like
to fuck down here round out the crowd
yeah Oh cuz people probably say not to
run - yeah it looks like the fight